remember that old iPhone 6 or 6 plus you
bought a year ago that you were so proud
of well that's now the old outdated
model Apple has just introduced the new
iPhone 6s and 6s plus the phones will
look familiar
their design is unchanged from a year
ago but under the hood there's a new
engine the handset is running at a nine
chip 70% faster than the a8 and the
iPhone 6 and Apple is heavily touting a
new feature called 3d touch tap it
softly and you activate an app as usual
but perform a so-called deep touch and
something new happens like
right-clicking on a mouse you get a
series of shortcuts press hard on the
mail app for example and you see options
like write an email in inbox 3d touch
does other things as well press hard on
a photo and it gives you a glimpse of
video or on the static photo Apple calls
this live photos the iPhone scammers are
also getting an upgrade the back facing
eyesight cameras now 12 megapixels up
from 8 and records video in the higher
quality 4k video format and the selfie
generation can rejoice the front-facing
FaceTime camera is getting a huge boost
to 5 megapixels up from 1.2 the new
iPhones come in silver space grey and
gold in addition to a new color they
call it rose gold but let's just agree
that it's pink the 6s starts at $1.99
for 16 gigabytes of memory and a
two-year contract the 6s plus starts at
$2.99 the phones go on sale on September
25th in the US and 15 other countries